so hello everybody as many of you know
for those who've been follow me on
social media for the last month or so
even more I have been working on this
giant marble monument and been carving
all day up to 11 hours a day and because
of that I've had a lot of time to listen
to podcasts you know the YouTube
sometimes plays and I'm just listening
and sometimes it ends up on these you
know it
autoplay goes on and I wounded up
listening to a podcast between Joe Rogan
and Douglas Murray some of you might
have heard this podcast in which they
talk about all the things that Douglas
Murray is interested in but during the
discussion they start to talk about
Bible stories and Christianity and they
start to make fun of different aspects
of the Bible and so I thought I would
look into at least one of those stories
to maybe you know I like Douglas and I
like drove but I maybe I can help all of
you understand this story in particular
it's the story of Elijah and the two
mother bears that kill the 42 youths
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so in this discussion Joe Rogan and
Douglas Murray start talking about the
the idea of wool and linen and how it's
so you know disturbing that in the Old
Testament you can't mix the two types of
cloth by the way for those who want you
can check out I actually made a video on
that subject trying to explain why it's
important so you can check that out I'll
probably put a link of that down below
in the description but that's not what I
want to talk about now what I want to
talk about is the story of Elijah which
was the book where the guy called upon
the she-bear to kill the children who
were mocking his baldness do you know
about that one
my favorite special a bald guy in that
story Elijah with Elijah who is his
master there are two prophets and Elijah
is going to go away and in order to go
away they cross this river they cross
the Jordan River and then Elijah is
taken up into heaven and as you light is
taken up into heaven then Elijah
receives these garments of Elijah and
receives a double take a double portion
of the spirit of Elijah and these
garments are these wooly garments these
hairy garments at the prophets wore
let's call him these garments of skin
and so Elijah gets these garments and
with the garments he hits the Jordan and
the Jordan separates into two and then
Elijah crosses over and then on the
other side as he's moving about I think
it's the the second story there's a
story just before that but the second
story after that is this story where a
bunch of yous come up to him and they
start to mock him and they call him
Baldy and they're saying hey Baldy get
out of here Baldy get out of here and
because of that Elijah turns to them
gets angry curses them and then these
two mother bears come out and they
devour all these young men
it says devour 42 of them so I can
understand Joe and and Douglas if you
ever listen to this I can understand why
you find that story strange
I would say you have to be very careful
and I hope that you know I think this
podcast was a bit old and I think now
that you've been listening to Jordan
Peterson a little bit more hopefully
you'll have a little bit more reserved
when you start making fun of these
stories and so I'm going to explain the
story to you now to understand the story
just like most stories in the Bible you
have to understand the patterns you have
to understand that this story of Elijah
and the she-bears is a repetition of
patterns which were there before their
repetition of I will show you one of the
examples of this pattern now Noah he
comes to the end of a world you know and
Enoch is taken up into heaven just like
Elijah is taken up into heaven and after
that Noah has to cross an expanse of
water just like he likes I had to cross
the Jordan Noah doesn't use the garments
of skin of animal skins but he has a
boat full of animals which is
symbolically very similar and so Elijah
uses these garments of animal skins to
cross over the water and so what he's
doing is he's actually in this moment of
transition he's crossing over to a new
world
a new beginning you could call it but in
the new beginning in this transitional
space a lot of things can happen a lot
of crazy things can happen and when Noah
cross is over after that there's a story
where just after he crosses the the
flood Noah is takes his clothes off gets
drunk and then he's lying there naked
you know in his tent and his son comes
in and sees that he is naked and then he
goes to tell his brothers now what's
implied in the story is that he's making
fun of his father or he's criticizing
his father for being naked in the tent
and then because of that the son of Noah
who saw him is cursed and he becomes
like a
cursing people in the world and you
think huh that's strange well you can
see first of all you first of all have
to see the pattern now notice the
pattern
Elijah crosses the waters with these
garments of animal skins then when he's
on the other side he is criticized for
something that he lacks he's criticized
for his nakedness in this case the fact
that he's bald the fact that you can see
his head it's okay this notion of
criticizing what the notion of exposing
the nakedness of someone of this is an
important theme in the Bible the idea
that when you do something certain
things that you can do will expose
someone's nakedness will expose their
vulnerability well it will expose their
weakness and the danger in doing that is
there's a process there's a pattern by
which that will then turn against you
and that will create something like a
curse against you the curse of the
mother bear that comes out and eats and
eats them you can really imagine it as
this kind of grumbling feminine energy
that comes up and then devours you like
a like a like a sea monster coming out
and eating Jonah or you know this idea
of the of this chaos kind of pulling you
down let's say and so that's what it
refers to now the reason why it's
she-bears reason why it's animals has to
do with this idea of covering and this
idea of the animal skins the idea of the
animals in the ark this idea that we
cover ourselves with let's say these
animal desires that we have around us
they they act as a way to protect
ourselves in the world everybody
understands that so you know you're
hungry you have sexual desire all these
things are there to help you survive in
a difficult world and but they're also
the thing that can pull you down you
know so if you let yourself
Oh too much to your hunger then you
become fat you become you know you're
taken over by that passion if you let
yourself get taken over by your sexual
desires then you become obsessed with
that and you you lose your focus you can
get a disease you you know everything
about letting yourselves go to these
passions that kind of eat you up and
drag you and so the danger of exposing
someone else's nakedness of exposing
someone else's lack is that then you
will become you will be eaten by the
thing that you are criticizing them for
lacking and so you see that the children
criticize the nakedness of the nakedness
of Elijah and then they're eaten by
these animal passions that you could
imagine that they're eaten by Elijah's
garments of skin those skins that he
used to cross over those skins that use
to survive in the world now you still I
know a lot of people think what does it
mean what are you talking about what is
this what does this have to do with
anything well we are going through that
right now we are experiencing exactly
this story of Elijah and the 42 youths
are being eaten right now it's called
the me2 movement some people in
Hollywood
some actors thought it on took it on
themselves and Hollywood in general to
criticize certain behaviors to poke at
the nakedness at the weaknesses of
others in high power and then what
happened those very people who accuse
others of that weakness then all these
women appeared in something to say yeah
but you to you you are guilty of the
thing that you're accusing me out and
those people got devoured by their own
weaknesses and so that which we hide we
have these these these sins we have
these passions that we hide for a reason
you know there are many reasons why we
hide our passions one is so that society
can continue one is that because we're
ashamed of them one is that because
we're trying to hopefully trying to get
away
from these passions but when you expose
someone else's passions then you run
into the danger that those passions will
then devour the person who's criticizing
you know and you see it it's so funny
because it's a trope that everybody
understands we've seen it we've seen
even people for example we've seen the
the gay lobby used that exact structure
they'll say things like if you criticize
homosexuality if you're openly critical
to people who are gay
it probably means that you secretly have
that desire in you and that you will
give in and be eaten up by that desire
and then they can point to different
conservative pastors or priests or
whatever who are found you know in some
some gay orgy or something and so and so
that is the structure of this story
and I think I think it's a it's
something that once you understand the
pattern you can see first of all the
pattern itself repeats itself in the
Bible there are other places where the
same pattern repeats itself but then
once you understand what it means then
you can understand that understand that
knowing this pattern can avoid a lot of
problems in your life and so I would say
to all of you just before you casually
mock a story in the Bible be very
careful because there's just probably
actually certainly more there than what
you thought at the outset so I hope you
enjoyed my discussion of Elijah and the
two bears if you want to go down this
rabbit hole I have talked about this
before several times on my channel if
you watch a video called Adam and Eve
and Batman you will see that I discussed
this very pattern how Batman uses his
giving in to fear at the death of his
parents to then turn fear against the
criminals and destroy them by the very
thing that exposed his own weakness and
his own vulnerability so this is a
pattern that you can find all over the
place
and so thank you again for listening and
watching don't forget my new website
www-what com if you like what I'm doing
please consider supporting me on patreon
and I will see you soon